hey everyone we're really excited to let
you know that what if in real life is
coming it's a couple of episodes with me
in real life I'm not here I'm like here
right I'm just a real person in a real
life put that back up but make sure to
watch for in real life from what if
okay one Earth is good but Two Earths is
even better
today we're taking our Blue Marble of a
planet and splitting it right down the
middle
what would you have to do to crack the
planet in two
which of these half earths would the
moon orbit
and why would neither of these halves
last very long
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we sliced Earth in half
there are many ways you could attempt to
divide the planet you could crack it
open with an asteroid blow it apart with
nuclear weapons or
start digging
but no matter what you'd have your work
cut out for you
having an asteroid do the job would be a
risky move
the one that made this 160 kilometer
wide 40 kilometer deep crater in South
Africa was bigger than the jigsalube
asteroid that killed the dinosaurs
a planet splitting Space Rock would need
to be much much bigger
and we wouldn't fare very well
now blowing things up could get messy
too
just to match the energy of the
dinosaur-killing asteroid you'd need to
set up at least one billion nuclear
bombs
to split the Earth in half you'd need to
make a ring of bombs running around the
globe
and yeah that idea probably wouldn't
work very well either
digging and cutting your way through the
planet seems like the least damaging
option and how hard could it be humans
dig things all the time right
well I hope you don't mind sweating up a
storm because things are about to get
high really hot
to start cutting through the planet well
first you'd need to get through the
crust and the best place to start
digging would be where this first layer
is the thinnest
that would mean venturing beneath the
ocean where the crust can be as little
as five kilometers in thickness
after that you'd be staring face to face
with the mantle at about 2 900
kilometers thick this would be the layer
you'd spend the most time working
through
but luckily the drilling would get a
little easier thanks to the fact that
the mantle is made up of partially
melted rock
but this layer is melted for a reason
it's incredibly hot
and the deeper you get the higher the
temperature and the pressure around you
would climb
you'd need some serious heat resistant
gear for this kind of work
even at the top of the mantle
temperatures can be as high as 1000
degrees Celsius
toward the bottom you'd be surrounded by
an even more scorching heat up to 3 700
degrees Celsius
then you'd run into a problem
the kind of heat resistant gear you need
to get through this next layer doesn't
exist
even tantalum hafnium carbide alloy the
most heat resistant material you'd have
at your disposal
wouldn't do you any good once you
reached the 4 000 degrees Celsius range
but for the sake of our scenario you'd
invent something new that would get you
the rest of the way through
now you'd be working through Earth's
2200 kilometer thick outer core
okay finally reaching the inner core of
our planet you'd be in for a serious
amount of heat
but not only that the pressure within
the core is 3.6 million times higher
than it is at sea level
yeah imagine all that pressure
unleashing as you tapped into the core
this would lead to an extremely violent
ejection of molten iron nickel and
silicates from the Earth's mantle
so it's a good thing you decided to
start drilling at the bottom of the
ocean otherwise this molten rock would
come all the way up on land to drown
Landscapes and create massive firestorms
now on the other hand drilling under
water you'd make a huge mess for a lot
of marine life
you'd keep drilling until you came out
on the other side at long last this
continuous ejection of all this material
from the core would Propel the two
halves away from each other the planet
would begin to separate
now one major consequence you probably
missed while planning this stunt is that
each half would start to collapse in on
itself almost immediately
you'd be lit
be let alone Away by powerful gusts of
wind as the atmosphere rushed to cover
the planet's broken sides all of that
thanks to gravity that would try to turn
these two semi-spheres into two spheres
luckily that process would take millions
of years
for now you should to check out what
crazy events would unfold on a split
Planet while you can
some of the things that are coming might
make you want to stitch these half
Earths back together again
for one this would really mess up our
magnetosphere
usually electric currents in the outer
core Drive the Earth's magnetic field
but thanks to cracking that wide open
liquid metal from the Earth's outer core
would begin to escape into space
core could cool down or stop churning
altogether and that means Earth would
lose the magnetic field that protects us
from dangerous solar radiation
without our magnetic field solar winds
would strip the atmosphere from the half
Earths before you even had a chance to
adapt to living there
and from there things would get even
worse
these two halves would be slowly
drifting further apart from each other
and the moon wouldn't like that
there's a chance that neither of The
Haves would have strong enough gravity
to keep a firm hold on our lunar
companion
yeah the moon might be set free to roam
as a rogue Space Rock
and without the moon well you can add
smaller Tides confused nocturnal animals
and a wobbly tilt on both halves of the
Earth to the list of upcoming disasters
but if these Two Earths stayed close
enough to each other we might just keep
the Moon
it would keep orbiting us in a new orbit
like a planet in a binary star system
this split would also wreak havoc on all
the satellites that provide vital
communication systems to both halves of
the globe like the internet
yeah if you wanted to use the internet
to communicate with friends and family
across space you'd have to hope that the
satellites take on a new orbit around
the half Earths
it's likely that most if not all of
these satellites would have their orbits
destabilized and as a result they could
be thrown out into space or come
crashing down onto either face of Earth
causing even more destruction
after all the initial chaos we'd have to
settle into the reality of life on a
split Earth
the two semi-spheres would keep slowly
moving away from each other
and instead of sending shuttles to the
moon or Mars
we'd be sending spaceships to the other
half of Earth to transport people and
fetch food and materials
one side of Earth might Supply the other
with certain types of produce well the
other could be the supplier of certain
Electronics or important minerals and
metals only buying anything that needs
to travel across space would become
enormously expensive
imagine a glass of milk costing upwards
of twenty thousand dollars in this
topsy-turvy divided reality
we probably should have experimented on
something less consequential to every
living thing on the planet
like splitting the moon in half
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
foreign